Before He Cheats was on that first album
and it blew up
[Music]
who was nervous the record company about
this
the my label people yes why were they
nervous about it he was aggressive it
was an aggressive song I just sang Jesus
Take the Wheel right and I I now it's
now she's getting violent and it worked
out though right that was the uh some
hearts is the is the best-selling debut
album from an American Idol contestant
you won the Grammy for Best New Artist
really in a way your career could have
gone anyway because it's pop it's a pop
record this is not a country record
it's it crossed over yeah I mean we we
kind of had on this album things with a
little more pop Flair and things with
more country Flair we kind of had we
were trying to ease me into
the music industry and you know I
definitely knew I I needed to sing
country music but I once the more more
country songs you know did as well as
they did it was like
any any doubters in my universe we're
like oh okay
so really it's a miracle when you think
about musical careers like I don't know
if being a musician it's a great thing
but it's also really a lot of pressure
because like you said you could have
just this one hit song and then gone
away
and that's just hurts you know it's it
just hurts that would have been way more
than than you ever would have expected I
guess I'm just grateful I'm grateful for
what I just said I wanted to sell enough
to be able to make a second album we
made a second album I was like I just
want to do well enough to make another
one like it was like every step of the
way was more than I could have ever
deserved and
we don't take those lyrics literally
right like you never destroyed someone's
car I've not no but yet I'm just kidding
but you like it you fantasize about it
that's the fun thing about music
um you do get to play a character you do
get to I don't know sing about things or
write things or make music videos or
whatever about things that you wouldn't
actually do in your life but it is fun
to to get into character and you know
act like you would and you know women
love that song yes oh I mean we it's
usually either it's towards the end of
the show or it's the Encore and I feel
like immediately when it comes in like
the whole audience just starts bumping
like there's this weird little like
undulation thing that just starts
happening
um crowd Comes Alive have you been
cheated on by a man yes you have were
you shocked that a guy was cheating on
you
um I mean at the time I was young and uh
how old were you I was in my 20s I was
in college okay and uh I feel like that
was a very big moment where it was like
I really thought I knew this person and
it turns out like I really did not know
this person that's that's the biggest
shock about being cheated on it it's
like oh my God this guy's a stranger to
me yeah I was were you in love with this
guy uh probably as as in love as a 20
something year old could be you know do
you ever do a guy thing like uh do you
because I do this do you ever think I
hope that guy who cheated on me
is watching this show or saw me do this
on this country music awards or you know
what I mean do you ever that kind of
Revenge turned you on a little bit
um I I don't think about it that much
anymore but I I you know earlier in my
career thinking about like he's probably
in the grocery store checkout line and
I'm on a I'm on a magazine I think there
is nothing better than becoming there's
a little pettiness yes absolutely I
think that makes sense
foreign